katie holmes and her new beau aren't
shying away from packing on the pda and
now a source is telling e.t the couple
is perfectly matched
it's exciting that's katie and her
boyfriend bobby wooten iii riding their
bikes on the streets of new york city
over the weekend the actress is rocking
an army green jacket over a black and
white striped shirt with a pair of red
sunglasses as for bobby he's also
sporting a casual look wearing a navy
jacket green shirt and shades too and at
one point during their outing the two
couldn't help but share a big passionate
smooch and following that sweet embrace
a source is opening up to e.t about the
couple explaining that although they
haven't been dating too long they're
really into each other katie and bobby
have been dating for a few months and
it's been going great both katie and
bobby are low-key and easy going our
source adds that while they're busy with
their own things katie acting and being
a mom and bobby with his music the two
cherish the time they get together
katie's latest romance comes nearly a
year after her split from chef emilio
vitolo the two called it quits in may
2021 with a source telling e.t at the
time distance between them was to blame
and prior to emilio katie dated jamie
foxx but the pair called it quits in
2019 after six years together but
katie's most famous relationship her
marriage to tom cruise the two tied the
knot in 2006 but divorced in 2012. they
share 16 year old daughter suri she
makes every day
great and awesome and better and i know
myself more because of her and when e.t
caught up with katie in the midst of the
pandemic she dished on celebrating her
daughter's birthday in quarantine how
did you make it special um when there
wasn't much that people could do
well i feel like
um
again this lock this laptop has had a
lot of silver linings and we've all
um you know i've really enjoyed having
even though i wasn't seeing my friends
in person but taking time to
facetime and really
be there um be present and
i think when
you have less you you're more creative i
mean it was a beautiful moment and i
think that
this year has also been a reminder of
like the simple things are
really beautiful and that is
those are the gifts of life
[Music]